prices here are ticking up and so is the
pain another day another petrol price
record it now costs over 95 pounds to
fill an average tank with unleaded over
a hundred to fill it with diesel
costly for all motorists crippling for
cabbies like javit
maybe i thinking if too much expensive
i have to look another job
yeah otherwise i carry this job but this
is my job like 17 years
the causes are complex but the war is
clearly key just look at what's happened
to the oil price peaking in march when
the invasion first happened and now
again as russian supplies sanctioned
the uk doesn't actually get all that
much oil from russia and it's already
being phased out but russia's shared
dominance in the global market means
that any uncertainty over it pushes up
prices for everyone and those price
rises aren't just felt by people at the
pumps but they trickle down touching so
many other parts of the economy and
pushing up other prices yet further
one key way that happens can be found
here haulage firms shouldering this
country's logistics heavy lifting
there's barely a good on the market that
won't at some point be loaded on and
driven in trucks like these
everything from furniture to food from
clothes to chemicals all exposed to the
fuel price
if you have a tyre blow out
that truck goes to work for the week for
nothing that's how tight the margins are
so when fuel goes up we've got to pass
it on we can't absorb there's no there's
no safety net in terms of
of margins presumably given also the
variety of goods you're transporting
all this stuff means inflation for
everyone
yeah of course me included you included
you know literally everyone
and oil impacts so much more than just
fuel here they make it to use ultra
durable plastic to be molded into goods
used in all parts of life
in the last two months we've had over 20
increases in the pla in the cost of the
plastics that we use
so we've obviously had to try and pass
those increases onto our customers which
has been very difficult for them
experts say fuel costs will likely rise
further there'll be very few businesses
or buyers of goods left untouched helen
and smith sky news in essex